[Musique]
cette semaine Mélanie nous propose un
rendez-vous sport à saincir l'école elle
est allée tester un cours de majorette
avec les cyiennes et ses professeurs ne
sont autres que les élèves de ce cours
découvertees de cette discipline en
image ce que j'ai dans les mains c'est
le bâton l'accessoire principal des
majorettes je suis au gymnase Gérard
Philippe de saint-y l'école avec les
saintsyriennes le club de la ville fondé
en 1968 et mes coach du jour sont roman
et Alicia bonjour les filles bonjour
alors elles ont 10 ans et 12 ans et
surtout elles sont vice championne de
France 2016 coach de choix les filles
première question est-ce que déjà j'ai
la bonne tenue oui oui super on commence
oui oui alors ça commence comment un
cours de majorette bah déjà faut avoir
le bâton à l'endroit alors faut toujours
avoir la la grosse boule en bas alors
pour commencer faut mettre son bras faut
tendre son bras faut passer toujours la
grosse boule audessus et la petite en
dessous en dessous alors on va
recommencer auudessus auudessus la
grosse boule auudessus ah ou et la
petite et la petite en
dessous les filles c'est difficile
d'être majorette ou
pas au début un petit peu puis après bah
après c'est pas en après après on est
dedans quand un amour fleur pendant des
semaines de qui se sour tout ça parce
qu'il s'aime à
Paris alors et ben vous pouvez montrer
déjà son bâton comme on met comme ça
voilà ah oui alors on fait bah une
figure 8 sauf à l'envers cette FO donc
en gros votre boule votre grande boule
elle passe comme
ça ah non d'accord alors on c'était
c'était dans l'autre droite en
faitou comme
ça et comme
ça et à force de faire ça et ben vous
faites c'est en faitre plus facile à
dire qu'à faire oui on passe la grande
boule ici puis
[Musique]
ici onence on passe elles sont pas
faciles he hop hop comme ça comme ça hop
voilà comme ça d'accord en fait j'ai pas
tout compris mais je pense qu'en vous
regardant au bout d'un moment ça va
rentrer donc et ça passe en dessous ou
audessus le bas pas facile du tout non
en fait pour être sincère c'est pas que
c'est pas facile c'est que c'est un peu
de
coordination et faut
réfléchir roman et aliciel ont bien
expliqué donc au bout de tris quatre
tentatives ça
[Musique]
rentre
roman et alici sentraîne elle depuis 6
ans il y a 53 major dans le club et ça
s'adresse à tout le monde que vous soyez
garçon ou fille alors pourquoi pas vous
Camille je vous ramène un bâton